just because it's a different island
doesn't mean you can't tether Traverse
yes the popular tether is back in Just
Cause 3 allowing you to traverse
scrapple and tether like never before
and if you thought that Rico's grapple
is all you'll be rocking think again
Just Cause 3 tosses in the next fan fave
the booster engine explosive mind now
these two gadgets are unlockable pretty
quick and it is in your best interest to
suit these babies up ASAP you do so by
grinding forwards called gear mods which
you get by completing the corresponding
gear challenges that are scattered
across the map once you get these two
gadgets modded up they will open up this
sandbox world in ways you cannot imagine
you will possess powers so powerful
nothing will stand in your way which is
why it needs to be said do not let these
powers overcome your mo you are to
liberate the peoples of Medici for the
peoples of the dead so Rico Rodriguez
king of the rebels here are your do's
and don'ts when using the grapple and
booster mines
do use tethers to destroy enemy fuel
tanks and statues delivery talents of
Medici don't forget to watch out for
civilians when pulling down propaganda
signs do shoot these gas tanks and then
tether a soldier to it
don't steal a civilians boat and then
tether them to it do grapple down onto
an enemy and push them off a cliff
don't grapple down onto a farmer just
for her tractor and then change her mind
take the time to admire the heights you
just Scrabble the pump don't tether the
wildlife humiliate the enemy by
tethering them to buildings and then
blowing them up don't
tether down a citizen just because he
was pestering you for an autograph
attach boosters to a plane's propellers
and then watch them spin before blowing
up
attach boosters to a civilians feet and
watch them spin before blowing up don't
be an idiot an attempt to attach a heavy
tank to a fighter jet and pitch for the
sky attach a tank to a powerful
helicopter by converging the tethers to
the tank center of mass fly the tank
over a heavily armed base eject wingsuit
down and grapple onto the following tank
crash land rain tear on the ground eject
and 10-8 the bombs I forgot to mention
that attacks earlier and finally do use
the tether to put boosters on a
vehicle's bottom and see how high you
can get don't use the tether on a
civilians bottom and see how high they
can get oh sorry about that that's it
for me see you next time I visit the
Mediterranean I think I'll check online
first make sure the country I'm visiting
is stable or maybe I'll just go skiing
upstate instead